the ball drop in New York City's Times
Square marked the start of many New
Year's resolutions but chances are many
of those goals may have already been
abandoned 2018 surveys showed almost 80%
of people broke their New Year's
resolution by the end of January some
people we spoke to in New York City told
us why the hardest part of maintaining
my resolution usually is sticking to it
the week after January 1st I've had to
restart my New Year's resolution four
times at least I also made a goal of
meditating like 10 minutes a day and I
haven't even started that so that one is
currently failing I feel like fear and
maybe habits and like perpetual habit is
what keep people from actually realizing
their resolutions they're hard to keep
but every now and again you should
people that's Axford teams clear author
of the New York Times best seller atomic
habits he's here to help us get back on
track good to see you again
that's good morning I like that we're
making a habit of seeing you here um why
do people 80% why do they fall off the
beam so fast yeah so when I wrote atomic
habits I kind of had two main goals one
is like how do we make habits easy
and second one is how do we make have it
stick and this time of year a lot of
people are kind of feeling that second
one you know you feel like oh I don't
have enough willpower or maybe if I just
had enough discipline and I would stick
to it but I think that this is maybe a
surprising thing that a lot of the time
people feel like what they lack is
motivation but what they really lack is
clarity so one of the first things you
can do is come up with a specific plan
for when and where to implement the
habit sounds simple but I will meditate
for one minute at 7 a.m. in my kitchen
or I will go for a run at 6 p.m. at this
park if you know exactly one where a
habit will occur you're more likely to
take advantage of that opportunity when
it arises so if you don't define it
correctly you're setting yourself up for
essentially failing I think that's right
and defining it is not just the time and
the place in the location but also the
size you know
the time we take on a habit that is much
too big and that's totally normal you
get ambitious at the beginning of the
year I'd like to read 30 books a year or
I want to you know work out for 45
minutes four days a week or whatever but
even if you start in a very small way
read one page meditate for one minute
write one sentence it doesn't sound like
a lot in the beginning but that's okay
because the main point is can i
reinforce being that kind of person
can I show up you know it's innocent but
you can make the argument that what's
even harder than keeping a habit is what
happens when you break it right and
coming back on and picking it back up
again what are some tips for people to
pick that habit back up even if they
miss a day or two sure so you know a lot
of people will start out strong at the
beginning of the year you do something
for two weeks or 17 days or whatever it
is and then you fall off the wagon and
at that point I think the mantra to keep
in mind is never missed twice we're not
talking about you don't have to be
perfect all the time but when you do
fall make sure that you try to get back
on track as quickly as possible this is
a particular true diets right diets have
seemed to be very all-or-nothing people
start a diet they do it for six days
then they go to happy hour or their
friends want to get a drink or something
and they think oh why bother I broke it
but I think the the never missed twice
idea is like well I wish I hadn't broke
my diet but never missed twice so let me
make sure I get back and have the next
meal be a healthy one you encourage
people to use a commitment device what
is that commitment devices can be a
really powerful way to get over either
procrastinating on a habit that you've
been avoiding or just kind of locking in
your future behavior so a quick example
let's say that you go to bed and you
think alright tomorrow's the day I'm
gonna wake up at 6 a.m. I'm gonna go for
a run but then 6 Amaral's around and
your bed is warm it's cold outside like
well maybe I'll just press snooze and
set yeah but if you rewind the clock and
you text a friend that day before and
you say hey let's meet at the park at
6:30 now you have a commitment device
because 6 am comes and it's still cold
outside and your bed is still warm right
now if you don't go to the park you're a
jerk because you leave your friend there
and commitment devices are little
strategies like that in this case of a
social accountability that help lock in
the future behavior and reduce the odds
II progress my resolution was to
exercise and in my head I say every damn
day and my thing was not to focus on the
goal not to
lose weight or run a marathon or
anything that I just said because and
get on just for ten minutes and then I
ended up spending a little bit more time
for instance on the treadmill and I kept
saying myself create this habit how long
does it take us to create a regularized
behavior so it's a good question it's
very common question the range you know
sometimes you hear 21 days or 30 days or
whatever if there was one study that
showed that 66 days is about the average
amount of time but even there it was you
know a couple weeks for an easy habit
all the way up to a few months for a
difficult habit but that question how
long does it take to build a habit I
think there's like a deeper assumption
behind it which is well how long until
it's easy or how long until I don't have
to stop you know how long so I don't
have to work hard anymore I think the
true answer the honest answer is how
long does it take to build a habit
forever because once you stop doing it
it's no longer a habit you say one of
the things in your book sorry I forget
about goals focus on systems instead I
think that this kind of encapsulates
what you had just mentioned a moment ago
like oh I want to show up every day
you're really focused on the system of
the behavior the the habits and
processes that lead to the outcomes you
want not the goal itself so it's so easy
to get wrapped up and did I read 50
books to lose 20 pounds what is the
outcome but really the focus in the
beginning should be did I show up my
fault I guess is there always a Jewish
New Year as well didn't work in January
I got some time feels like you've made
the habit when you miss not doing it so
the one page that you read when you
don't do it you feel like oh I miss not
doing that that's can be one way to
define what a habit is right at some
point of behavior becomes so easy that
it's more work to not do it than to do
it and so reading one page writing one
sentence things like that pull you in
because they feel so silly or simple
it's like we'll be silly to not do this
all right well we'll have you back soon
enough thank you